all right welcome back to the ingram
angle here from las vegas we're almost
now four months after that deadly mass
shooting the worst in american history
why do we still have so many unanswered
questions let's turn to a couple of
experts to break it all down former LAPD
detective Mark Fuhrman who became a
household name of course during the OJ
Simpson trial and Randi Sutton a former
lieutenant with the Las Vegas
metropolitan Police Department great to
see both of you mark let's start with
you it is for months almost since the
shooting and we're now only hearing that
they might be charging another
individual after we've heard almost
nothing from the Las Vegas police
department and after the press had to
press for a lot of these documents to be
released what's going on here well Laura
let's let's pause for a second and
understand that we had fifty eight
homicides that's 58 individual homicide
investigations and hundreds of people
that were wounded and that had to be
documented and handled by the detectives
we haven't heard from one detective yet
in this which is unfortunate but let's
look at some of the things that had to
be processed and one is DNA if there was
DNA on anything that paddock handled
that was in that room they probably
pursued that and it is probably his
girlfriend that they're actually
targeting but I don't think that's gonna
solve anything in this case as far as
why the motive or really how paddock
actually pulled this off
Randi you were you know veteran of the
Las Vegas police department and I have a
couple friends that you probably know
who were homicide detectives they're
just retired a couple of years ago and
it's a tight-knit group at the Las Vegas
police they deal with a lot every day
but this was so horrific on every level
and what happens when we don't have a
regular updates or even press you know
briefings I think in a case like this is
that people start saying well what's
really going on well why aren't we
seeing but where's the video of Steven
paddock checking into the hotel I've
been asking this question my producers
like laugh at me cuz I asked the
question like everyday where's the video
Stevan paddock checking into the hotel
nobody ever gives me an answer well
there's a lot there's a lot of going
there's a lot going on here and and one
of the things that you've probably heard
and and is been inexplicable to me is
that when when Metro took on this
investigation and the the scope of it of
course is huge for some reason a
decision was made to relieve the
homicide unit of this investigation and
give it to a rather innocuous unit that
handles officer-involved shootings
that's one of the that's one of the
major questions that I have had and you
know here's the thing that the initial
law enforcement response was amazing
courage that these officers showed and
and the dedication that they showed was
absolutely stunning
and and but then you have this this
media blackout as you have termed it and
and it's it's very difficult to
understand it's it's a little
inexplicable to me how the the sheriff
has not been keeping the public so this
you're not gonna say this but Randy did
they screw up and it or are they worried
that Vegas I mean it's a place that
survives on tourism people have to feel
safe they have to feel like when they
check into a hotel there's not a guy
checking ten bags with thousands of
rounds of ammunition is going to be in
the next hotel room and like I get I get
these casinos they want to be thriving
and hiring people I get it but I find
this to be really odd and frankly
infuriating that we got the big
brush-off from the from the police today
we're big supporters of the police we
got a big brush-off no we're going to
talk about what do you mean they're
gonna talk about it we're not asking you
to compromise the investigation what why
do we know so little about his movements
inside that hotel and no one ever went
inside the hotel with him no one no one
came in and out no maids they never you
know we've never where's that security
guard he was on Ellen for goodness sakes
he didn't want appearance on ellen
because she has some deal with a
Mandalay Bay Hotel well there's no doubt
well first of all did the police screw
up in this no they didn't they've
handled this investigation
at the initial outset with with the
professionalism that one would expect
however you know when you talk about
giving the responsibility of this
investigation to the proper authorities
well that would be the Homicide Unit
that's they're great guys so a firm I
should get permanent on this mark mark
okay I don't you know I'm a big support
of the police everyone knows that but
this was fifth we have 58 Americans dead
we had you know 498 injured and or or
monkeying around with oh we're not going
to release this search warrant we're not
going to release that search warrant we
apparently we have one woman who got
paid money while while this thing was
happening why he wired her money she
deleted her Facebook account mark before
his name was even released to the public
she's deleting Facebook accounts this is
odd well Laura Randi is absolutely
correct I think it's a slap in the face
of the homicide detectives that do this
for a living and officer-involved
shooting team they also deal with deaths
but it's usually involved with officers
and I'm sure that the thought process
was that they handle a lot of ballistics
and a lot of tracking the path of
bullets and they'd be better handled or
better I guess informed to handle this
since the shooter is dead that being
said the one thing I didn't like about
this investigation you had too many
heavies too many chiefs too many from
the white the the big tower talking in
these press conferences instead of the
people that actually do this for a
living I think that's one of the things
that became a mistake that now we don't
have that information we also have civil
litigation we have hundreds of civil
lawsuits that are undoubtedly very
haunting at in the city of the city of
Las Vegas Mandalay Bay the police
department even though I believe just
like Randi the Police Department did
nothing because they they had such a
small window to actually act and I think
they did it as he's put bravely and
heroically and they actually closed as
fast as they could with the suspect but
Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas
an elected official that's handling the
investigation as sheriff I think there's
a lot of unsaid politics going on here
then go follow the money I believe
they're just they're slowing it down
follow the money there's not there's no
doubt in my mind there's no doubt in my
mind that the Mandalay Bay is one
controlling the information yeah well
especially when it comes to their
employee Campos
I mean he disappeared after appearing on
Ellen that was that was very controlling
I mean I mean